one of the amazing things you're part of
is the
ai institute for artificial intelligence
and fundamental interactions
what's up with this institute what are
you working on what are you thinking
about
the idea is something i'm very on fire
with which is basically ai meets physics
and um you know it's been almost five
years now since i shifted my own
mit research from physics to machine
learning and in the beginning i noticed
a lot of my colleagues even though they
were polite about it well that kind of
what is max doing what is this weird
stuff he's lost his mind
then but then gradually i uh together
with some colleagues we're able to
persuade more and more of the other
professors
in the our physics department to get
interested in this and and um
now we got this amazing nsf center so
for 20 million bucks for
for the next five years mit and a bunch
of neighboring universities here also
and i noticed now those colleagues
looking at me funny have stopped asking
what the point is of this because it's
becoming more clear
and i really believe that of course ai
can help
physics a lot to do better physics
but physics can also help ai a lot
both by building better hardware
my colleague marin suljacic for example
is working on
an optical chip for much faster machine
learning where the
computation is done not by moving
electrons around and
but we're moving photons around
dramatically less energy use
faster better we can we can also help
ai a lot i think by having a
different set of tools and a different
maybe more audacious attitude
you know ai has to significant extent
been an engineering discipline where
you're just trying to make things that
work
and being less more interested in maybe
selling them then figuring out exactly
how they work and proving theorems about
that they will always work right
contrast that with physics you know when
elon musk sends a rocket
to the international space station they
didn't just train with machine learning
oh let's fire it a little bit left more
to the left a bit more to the right so
that also missed let's try here
no you know we figured out newton's laws
of gravitation
and other and got other things and got a
really deep fundamental understanding
uh and that's what gives us such
confidence
in in rockets and my vision is that
in the future all machine learning
systems that actually have impact on on
people's lives will be understood
at a really really deep level right so
we trust them
not because some sales rep told us to
but because they've earned our trust
we can and really safety critical things
even prove
that they will always do you know what
we expect them to do that's very much
the physics mindset so
it's interesting if you look at big
breakthroughs that have happened in
machine learning
this year you know from dancing robots
you know it's pretty fantastic not just
because it's cool but
if you just think about not that many
years ago this
youtube video at this darpa challenge
where the mit robot
comes out of the car and face plants
yeah
how far we've come in just a few years
similarly alpha fold to you know
crushing the protein folding problem we
can talk more about
implications for medical research and
stuff but hey you know
that's huge progress i you can look at
the
gpt3 they can spout off
english text which sometimes really
really blows you away
you can look at the google deepmind's
mu0 which doesn't just kick your butt
and
go and chess and shogi but also in all
these atari games and you don't even
have to teach it the rules now
you know what all of those have in
common is besides being powerful
is we don't fully understand how they
work
and that's fine if it's just some
dancing robots and the worst thing that
can happen is they face plant right
or if they're playing go and the worst
thing that can happen is that they make
a bad move and lose the game right
it's less fine if that's what's
controlling your self-driving car
or your nuclear power plant and
we've seen already that even though
hollywood
had all these movies where they try to
make us worry about the wrong things
like
machines turning evil the actual
bad things that have happened with
automation have not been machines
turning evil they've been caused by over
trust in things we didn't understand as
well as we thought we did right even
very simple automated systems like
what the boeing put into the 737 max
right yes killed a lot of people was it
that that little simple system was evil
of course not
but we didn't understand it as well as
we should have right
and we trusted without understanding
exactly we over trust we didn't even
understand that we didn't understand
you